So on my foraging
journey, I met this one.
It's pure sugar.
Imagine, when you are
out there, starving,
and suddenly there is sugar.
In the middle of that
little thing there,
you've got little insects.
The insects build
a little house,
and inside is pure sugar.
Other tricks, you can
use a lot of things,
including water
plant, lotus plant,
and not all of them are edible,
and not all of them
are edible raw.
Some of them, you cook them,
they lose the toxicity.
You really have to
know what you're doing.
And this is the
knowledge by the way,
coming from the
Aboriginal people only.
Is not my knowledge.
This is only from the knowledge
of those 60,000 years,
they've been living there.
And sometimes,
when you are there,
I wondering, I'm never
wondering why I'm out there,
I'm wondering what is out there.
Because, I have to make
a confession to you guys.
I still don't know
why I'm walking.
Imagine.
I've ran all around
the planet, once.
It's a lot of walking.
And I still don't know.
We don't always have to know.
We don't always
have to know things.
But the reality, it's
not what you think,
it's what you feel.
What you feel's right for you,
you must do.
This is a really good day.
This is like a, foof, five
star, top left corner,
we've got a little wood
house, it's like a tumor
in one type of eucalyptus.
We've got a little
hole in the middle.
Inside, we've got a soft shell,
like really soft soft shell,
and it's like a little
bed, and inside the bed
you've got insect, little grubs.
And you chuck that in a
fire, cook a little bit,
when the smokes get
out of the little hole,
it's cooked, you can eat
the bugs and the bed.
Lovely.
Top, red thing called dog balls.
Really sweet and
powerful vitamin C,
really difficult to
find, really rare,
grow in a really high grass.
You really have to have
an eye for this one.
Really happy to
find it because that
will cut my hunger at night.
On the right corner, we've got,
some really, we call
that wild peach.
Doesn't taste like
a peach at all.
It's really sour, but
I like to have that
in my mouth, to makes my
mouth watering during the day.
And finally, the
main five star food,
will help me along
the way a lot,
it's this one.
This is the boab nut.
The boab nut come
from the boab tree,
and this tree teach me so much.
So, this is amazing
takeaway food.
See this fruit?
This is the boab
nut, and inside,
you've got what I can eat.
It's a lot of work, always,
involving that process.
So you have to smash the
little powder thing inside,
you will find 15
to 20 little nuts.
And then, those nuts,
you have to roast them,
on a fire, but not too hot.
You have to make a fire,
take the fire away,
and roast it under hot sand.
And then only, you can
smash it between two stones,
and start to eat the
little white meat inside.
So it's a lot of
process and work, but,
really good news, right?
Food that actually
I can carry with me.
This is amazing thing.
Really powerful food, also.
Typical afternoon, in my house.
End of the day, after
really hot day because
I have to say it's really hot,
and during this time,
because you've got two different
times when you can do this.
It's during the wet
season, or the dry season.
I decided to do the
dry season thing.
More easy, right.
But that was also
the bushfire season,
so I will have this
pressure constantly,
of having my nose in
the wind all the time
to smell what's
going on in the air,
because if there's a
bushfire coming in,
you need to react straight away,
knowing that a bushfire
goes 40 kilometers an hour,
it's really fast.
So typically there, I've
got this flat stone here,
and I will be smashing the
boab nuts on the stone.
That's all I will eat.
And, of course, fishing.
Well, those water there,
they are salty water.
Brackish, as they call
that in Australia.
So they are tidal water.
On the bottom you've
got the sweet water,
on the top you've
got the salt water.
So if you want to
drink some water,
you need to wait when
the tide goes down,
and only you can drink water.
So, that's also
tricky, for fishing.
Because depend of the tide,
you've got the type
of fish in it or not.
So, you kind of happy
to have a fish, right?
So let me tell you a
story about that fish.
This fish, it toxic.
You've got this little back
fin here, on the spine.
If you touch that,
not long to live.
That's why I put a piece of
wood in its mouth, like that.
So the first fish, I'm
an excellent fisherwoman,
really excellent,
because I grew up,
we were going, not on holiday,
we were going fishing with
my father, or my brother.
So I'm good at this.
So the first fish
that I actually took,
was like a kid, this fish
was jumping out of the water,
I would be like so happy!
I can still see this
fish jumping out.
So then later the next thing
I hear was like, splash.
Crocodile gets it.
I was like, really?!
How I'm going to do these thing?
I'm doing all the work, and
they're going to eat all, what?!
Not on my watch!
So there's always
a solution, right?
I been thinking a little bit,
I'm going to get you guys.
I noticed that I was doing it,
more I was doing a little
noise on top of the water.
More they're attracted
to the noise, right?
So I will do that.
And then, on purpose, I
would retrieve my stuff,
and get to my second
point, 150 meters away,
and fish really quietly here.
And grab my fish, and go
back to my point and say,
haha, got one (laughs).
But, I'm always a fair player,
because I will
always share my food.
This is the rule in the bush,
this is the rule with nature,
I always share my food.
So I will cut the fish,
take the guts out,
cut the head, and I will
give it to those amazing
friends of mine, which is
the sweetwater crocodiles.
How cute they are!
They're looking at you!
You can't not fall in
love with those things.
And they are so passion,
and they are there waiting,
and you give them something,
like little puppy really.
They become my friend and
my soulmate out there.
There was nobody, no
human, no sign of human,
only snakes, crocodiles.
And them...
So, once I get the fish, you
have to still to cook the fish,
so the best way to cook a fish,
and be able to eat
all of the meat,
is to cook in the
water, simple like that.
And interestingly, I had
some salt and pepper with me,
never use it.
I love the taste of the food,
of the fiber, of nature.
So sometimes, when
you are there,
I had a chance to wash myself.
Imagine.
So, this is a natural soap.
It's one extremity
of a eucalyptus tree.
So, I took this, and if you
smash it between your hands,
in the water, it's got the
saturation and saponin,
it's actually like a soap.
It's amazing, make
your hair so shiny,
and really works, really.
And the good thing
also about this trick,
it's if you are in
a small billabong,
you can actually do
that in the water,
and that will make a saturation
of oxygen in the water,
and the fish living there
will come up in the surface,
with the tummy up,
looking for oxygen.
You just have to
collect your dinner.
Thanks to the Aboriginal people.
So when you are there like that,
you can wash, but not like here.
One day it's the left foot,
another day it's the right one.
Little bit after,
anyway, in my country, a good
cheese is a smelly cheese.
So, back to the action.
This is a typical camp.
Things always two
knife, you notice?
In case if I forgot one.
Or in case if I lose
one in an emergency.
But I will never
sleep near the water.
It's the last thing
you have to do.
I will actually stay there,
the water is just not far off,
collect my food,
fishing, then that day
I noticed some
tracks on the sand.
I saw there was
some dingos around.
So, rather than giving the
inside guts of the fish
to the crocodile, I will
leave it on the side,
cause I know that will be
little four legs friend
coming to get it.
Anyway, I finish my day,
eat, collect everything,
walk off, because
those crocodiles,
can actually put their legs
up and walk five kilometers
inland, so you better know
where you're sleeping.
Pretty high up, right?
There was this typical
thing up there,
where crocodile
eat German people.
What happened, those
German people get drunk,
and they are feeling
really powerful,
and they kind of
sleep near the water,
thinking, you know, you're
not going to get me here,
20 meters from the water.
They sleep in the
tent, completely drunk.
The crocodiles come at night,
take the bottom of the tent,
and withdraw the tent,
get in the water,
and turn the tent, and
the guy is inside the tent
half-drunk, and he's
going to do spin,
washing machine spin, and he
doesn't know what's going on,
until he's dead.
So, all those stories,
I was aware of.
So, really every single night,
I would go in safe spot.
And so what does it
mean, a safe spot?
Where to go?
Where to find my way?
So I will study those
topographic map forever.
This is my skills,
I'm so good with maps.
Good all maps, you know.
Good compass, good
on maps, all I need.
Well this map, it's
actually dated 1972.
Because the government
doesn't do any new map
from there, there is no need.
So, but the mountains
doesn't move.
So, I will study those forever,
because the secret is there.
You have to listen to
the landscape, to be.
If you want to find water,
you need to be the water.
If I was the water,
if I was the stream,
where I will go?
You have to imagine.
If you want to find a fish,
you need to be the fish.
Because you need to get in
touch with who we are inside,
and inside, all of us here,
the magical news that
I've got tonight,
that we are animals.
We are mammals after all.
Half of it.
And the good thing about it,
is we can get in touch
with that animality.
That would help us a lot
during everyday life.
I use that a lot.
I smell, if I come near you
and I start smelling you,
don't worry too much, right?
Really, we've got senses.
You know, the communication
between two human beings,
it's only 7% on the
conversation, on words.
The rest, it's invisible.
The rest is smell,
attitude, feeling.
We use our senses, we
don't realize at all,
and out there, is the
only thing you can do,
get in touch with
your animality.
And when you're
starving, I remember,
in the Gobi Desert,
there's a precious moment
where after six months
of walking, sweating,
painful body.
I wake up, open my
tent, I'm in the Gobi,
there's nothing around me.
Only sand, wind, and
type of rocky thing.
Nothing too exciting.
Open the thing, and
suddenly that day,
I was like a little ice
cube, melting in the sand,
and I become the wind,
the sand, the rocks.
I become one with nature.
I believe today, it's
why I'm actually walking.
Is to get this link, this
touch, with who we are.
This touch with where
we've got the feet on,
we are on this
planet, all of us.
We do not have boundaries,
we belong to this planet.
This is the magic of it.
Well, it's really good diet.
After three weeks
I lose 12 kilogram.
It's quite quick, fast.
Really, walking 12 hours a day,
try to catch my
food, it was quite,
really a difficult task.
But, that was not to
forgot my determination
in this journey.
How we can be so determined,
how we can go for
a dream that bad?
Well, there is no recipe.
Because, the
currency: sweat, pain,
but happiness, yes,
happiness, fun,
sense of humor, do not
forgot your sense of humor,
is the most important thing
you will have with you,
all your life.
That's what I've got
in my survival kit.
First, when people ask me,
what you've got in
your surviving kit?
I say, "my sense of humor, do
not walk out of the door"
"without it."
So because you need it, see.
When you've got this
kind of terrain to cross,
this is a swamp.
I need to cross that swamp,
and on the bottom of that
swamp, there is water.
Big hole in some places.
And inside those hole,
you've got crocodiles.
And snakes, falling
from the tree.
And,
big wild bull, frozen
bull not moving,
hearing you moving through
those dry Pandanus leaves.
See, the floor is full
of those Pandanus leaves.
Dry ones, so whatever
you're doing,
you're making too much noise.
They hear you coming in.
It's like playing a little
bit with the life you've got.
So you have to trust
something, in one stage.
You have to trust,
in your,
capability of
melting with nature.
Because I know I'm
in the right spot.
I know that what I'm doing,
it's where I'm supposed to be.
And this is the only way
to understand nature.
If every one of us here tonight,
know where they belong to,
it's a magical step to take.
So, I was in the this
building before I leave
for this expedition.
Talking with the senior
photographer editor here,
and she was saying
to me, well, Sarah,
you don't want
video crew with you.
Can you just do one concession?
Imagine if I give
you a photographer,
like a few days.
Imagine, six days before
the end of your journey,
I get the photographer
on location,
and photographer follow you.
I was, you know, like
concession a little bit,
you have to be
flexible a little bit.
I say, okay, let's do
this, on one condition.
Has to be a cute
male photographer.
Imagine, I'm out
there for so long,
and she say, okay, I do my best.
Helicopter arrive, and this
is the person who walk out.
I do not know what this
woman didn't understand
about the cute photographer.
That was a woman!
And I can see this woman
walking off the chopper,
the helicopter, say
hi, I'm Krystle.
I look at her and
say, you're not a man.
She was a bit shocked.
She had a little
bit briefing before,
knowing that I'm not going to
be that easy to work with.
And anyway, we go on
this amazing trip.
She was unbelievable, all
the crazy pictures you saw,
amazing picture,
that's come from her,
her name is Krystle Wright,
she's amazing photographer,
National Geographic
photographer.
And on the top of it,
she played a game.
She's been really foraging
for her own food, also.
She knows all about
bush tracker by now.
And when,
when we walked
together, at night,
we exhausted, really.
We make a little fire for
the sake of it, really.
Boil some hot water, I'll
be starving going to bed,
counting the days
like, four days to go.
But at the end of the
day, when the light is off
in her little tent, because
I would have my little tent,
she would have her little tent,
the night is quiet, I would
hear some (crinkling),
wrapping paper going on.
Like, what?!
Darling?
What's going on?
Oh, you don't want to know.
No, I do want to know.
Talk to me, at least talk to me,
I can't handle this.
I want to know.
Curiosity, it's not
one of my fortes,
I need to know.
Talk to me!
She said, "okay."
"Flatbread with tuna."
Because, it was, of course
she would bring food with her.
She's working.
And so, every night we
would have this little game
going on at night.
To my little, I was like,
okay, three days to go,
Sarah, you can do this.
Every night was
getting more difficult,
I was getting more starving.
And one night, I hear
this unusual noise.
Looks like a jar,
plastic jar thing.
Yeah.
And I say, okay.
New, this is new, right?
She said, no, no no, no.
No yeah, that's new.
I never heard it.
And she couldn't
speak pretty much,
she had something in her mouth.
And I was like, what is it?
Mm, nothing.
(loud chewing)
Nothing really.
I said, talk to me.
It's Nutella.
She was eating Nutella
with a spoon, seriously.
Anyway, she tested
my power inside me,
and we will make joke about
it during the journey.
She will wait, really,
at the end of the day,
to actually eat
something in her tent,
not tempting me or not
be eating in front of me.
So the magic of those journey,
the magical way of walking
through this planet,
been doing this for 23 years.
I walked basically everywhere.
What I can take out with me,
If I have to take
one phrase out,
will be this one.
Let your soul touch the earth.
Go walking.
Because this is the most
beautiful thing we can do.
Get this connection
with the planet.
And, feel connected,
to the universe,
and have faith on what
we are, as a species,
in this planet.
Because we are all connected,
that we want it or not.
We are this spiderweb of
people connected to each other.
And only thing we can do
is really understand
this connection,
that we've got with each
other on the planet.
And start to look after her,
because after all, the
planet doesn't need us.
We need the planet.
And this is my arrow, my
mom, my cute little mom,
she will support me all
through my childhood,
my adult life, and she was
this really smart soul.
She would say to me,
Sarah, do you want to do
your homework, or
clean your room?
Well, I had the choice, right?
So she's been this really
smart, incredible mom,
supporting me.
And she doesn't know
a word in English.
She doesn't travel at all.
But, she will be
there, on location,
in every expedition
I will finish.
She'll be there for me.
And on the left,
it's my assistant,
slash cousin, all the family's
involved in my expedition.
And one day,
I did the last
bit, the last step.
And this looked like this.
There is this heart, inside me,
will take me out there
walking again, and again,
and again, and again.
Because I've been doing
this for 23 years.
I know, this really
strange feeling,
which is like a
link with nature,
a direct connection with
nature that I've got,
I know I will follow
that pain again,
to go back again, to
nature, with my two feet.
Because I believe humans can
get along with nature again.
Thank you very much.
(applause)